before the video starts guys please
please listen to this for two seconds
please yeah this is an amazing thing
that I hate them said shed is going to
change the way you give in charity
before you do that guys in the comment
section there is four links I'm going to
put where if you guys conditional giving
sadaqa just made after you watch this
video make the intentions will she hate
him what he says and give to one of the
four inshallah promises as you guys know
prophet ISA passed away we're building
an a miscibility a Masjid the school a
playground and a water well on his name
in sha Allah on behalf of his name
sadaqa jariya
also trying to support family the links
will be there inshallah and also links
for other organizations as well so there
before in total you pick who you want to
give to inshaallah may allah bless you
enjoyed this video and way to receive
asha item says but in order to increase
even the reward of sadaqa listen to this
please listen to this I got it from one
of my scholars me Allah Allah Allah
reward him
[Music]
hi Eddie so honey limo feeds up
[Music]
check out sponsors nature's blend they
specialize in premium Ethiopian black
seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the sooner you can also use this
Concord Salam 10 for temps in of their
products you know brothers and sisters
sadaqa/charity any amount even if it is
very small is one of the best deeds the
best did that Allah Jalla WA ala will
take it in his right hand and keep
growing it for us the virtues of sada
are unlimited subhanAllah but in order
to increase even the reward of sadaqa
listen to this please listen to this I
got it from one of my scholars may Allah
Allah Allah reward him once I saw him
having a paper and he was looking at
that paper and then he was in a way so I
said to him here
what is this so anyway he was
embarrassed but then he told me what is
that he said I have a list of those whom
I am giving sadaqa on their behalf
I said hon Allah this is really amazing
so in the beginning and I forgot
actually whether he put his parents
first or himself first
that he is giving sadaqa on their behalf
and then his children so his parents his
children he has a grand children his
grandchildren his other relatives his
brothers sisters even nephews nice and
the some of the neighbors all the
neighbors I don't remember exactly and
what is amazing two things
suhan Allah two things one of them is
those whom have lost whom I have done
any mistake or those who those who have
rights over me yeah those who have
rights over me I made any mistake
against them I oppressed them I took
their rights unlawfully and
he said to me sure sometimes you might
done you might annoy someone and you
don't want to those people as the
prophet sallallaahu Selim says to take
your has an ad on the day of
resurrection you don't want your has an
ad to go to them or their sins to be put
on your shoulders so give sada up on
their behalf and the second amazing
thing that I found is he is saying and
the sadaqa on behalf of all Muslims this
is really amazing I learned from this
and I copied that and you can have it on
your mobile just a simple message and
whenever you give sadaqa look at this to
remind yourselves of those whom you are
giving sadaqa on their behalf not only
that as he told me sometimes when i give
sadaqa and i say o allah
this sadaqa on behalf of all who are
listed on that paper so you don't need
to look at them just intended that and
so Hanauma many people said to me but if
you intend it on behalf of others then
their world will go to others it will
not go to you no this is not true who
told you the prophet sallal Arya Salem
says in the Menomonee vignette actions
are judged by intention and you will get
whatever you intend so if you intended
at your celica will benefit others and
if you intend that your sadaqa is on
behalf of others as well
so you will get a reward for that sadaqa
and they will get every one of them will
get the same reward Allah Allah Allah is
Allah the most generous he will not
divide the reward between you and others
we are the people who define not Allah
the most generous person and have
personal plan below have good thoughts
about Allah Allah Allah that he will
give all of you the similar reward not
only that but you the one who gave sada
up on behalf of them you will get the
maximum because what you have given the
sadaqa and also you
gave Sadiq on their behalf so you helped
them as well so brothers and sisters why
to lose this great opportunity remember
when the person is on his deathbed the
last minute he will ask him Allah Allah
to be delayed for one second to do what
not to pray not to do other things but
to give sadaqa because you can't give it
just like this yeah in one second and
the prophet sallallaahu Salim said put a
shield between you and Hellfire by
giving sadaqa even if it is what a piece
of a date subhanAllah
so brothers sisters whenever you give
any amount of sadaqa say Ya Allah this
is on behalf of all of those in this
list and is better that you look at the
list it is really amazing